[موسيقى]
تواجه السلطات تحديات فرضها واقع ما بعد
الزلزال وتحديدا في القطاع السياحي كان
يقصد مراكش سنويا مئات الالاف من السياح
الاجانب فخلال النصف الاول من العام
الجاري تخطى عددهم مليو ونصف مليون سائح
ويعتمد اقتصاد المدينه على النشاط السياحي
والصناعات التقليديه يقدر عدد الحرفيين
بمراكش بنحو 120 الف صانع تقليدي وتعد دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي الوجهه الاولى للمنتجات
التقليديه المحليه تليها الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه هذه مدرسه ابن يوسف العتيقه
يعود عمرها الى القرن الثال عشر وعام
2017 اعطى العاهل المغربي الملك محمد
السادس تعليماته لاعاده ترميمها على
الطراز المغربي الاصيل في القرن الث ع
كانت واحد الحركيه كبيره في العهد المريني
ديال المدارس العتيقه اللي كينه ف هذذه
مدرسه اللي فيها جميع المكونات ديال
المدرسه وديال التعليم وديال التكوين فيها
هناك هذا الصحن اللي كتشوفو الان هو الصحن
فيه مسجل ولكن كذلك في غرف للطلبه هناك
غرف للطلبه فكان ا هذ المدارس في المغرب
هو شيء جميل انه كانوا الطلبه كيجيو من
جميع انحاء من احواز مراكش ومن من مدن
اخرى للتعليم
ولتحت فقهاء
وعلماء مراكش تشكل جزء من تاريخ المغرب
وتعد منطقه تراثيه منذ تشييدها عام 20070
وظلت لقرون طويله عاصمه الدوله المغربيه
بدءا من عهد المرابطين ومركزا اقتصاديا
ومناره ثقافيه وهي المصنفه عالميا ضمن
التراث الانساني من منظمه اليونسكو
[موسيقى]